hey i'm not even starting with some
stupid joke this time like
can we please just give a round of
applause for shield bringing back bill
paxton's character through his son james
what an amazing tribute now as you can
probably guess i'm very excited to talk
about this week's episode of agents of
shield
there's a lot going on in it and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the entire thing
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want anything
ruined then i recommend that you turn
off now
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoyed
the video and make sure you subscribe to
the channel
for breakdowns on the show week by week
without the way
this is the heavy spoiler show i'm your
host definition
now let's get into our breakdown of
episode 10.
okay so a super villain walks into a bar
that's not a joke either that's that's
just how the episode starts
now nathaniel malek is out and about
recruiting all the bad guys he can
and he goes to a young john garrett
saying he wants him on board his team
he reveals everything that's going to
happen to him and how he will eventually
become a member of hydra
after shield refused to rescue him in
case you don't know
what malek told jon happened in the
original timeline
and this led to the character becoming
the first subject of project death lock
jon became a villain known as the
clairvoyant who due to his level 7
shield clearance
was able to gain access to several
special ops and stop them before they
were able to fully complete their
mission
jon also became a sort of surrogate
father to grant ward
and his relationship mimicked coulsons
with daisy
providing a sort of family war in the
earlier seasons
john was eventually killed by coulson
but by the way that the events play out
in this season
i don't think that we can take any of
the past timeline it's a given
malik gives him the big pitch and jon
initially doesn't believe his prophecies
but after the villain shows off his
quake powers jon decides to join him in
his quest for world domination
with the title screen we get to confirm
that we're back in the 80s once more
and at the lighthouse the group meet
back up with roxy glass
who's become a fully fledged shield
agent we learn that the rest of the team
also joined up with the group
but that they're on different
assignments however she hopes that they
will be reunited with them at the
triskelion
coulson states that it shouldn't
actually be built yet
which further hammers home just how
badly the intervention of the chrono
comes has messed up the timeline
they realize that they need to put
things back to the way that they were
and thus decide to help out afterlife in
their fight against malik
elsewhere in one of the basement labs
daisy questioned simmons over why
owaishi had a breakdown last week
over remembering what happened with fitz
due to the loop correcting everything
simmons doesn't actually remember any of
this anymore and thus
can't really help out we'll get into
more of this in the breakdown but
there's definitely a lot of questions
hovering around what's happening with
bits in this entry
they reach out to jaya ying who
teleports in with gordon
and we jump across to malik showing john
around his home
since the events of episode 8 he and his
group have taken over afterlife
and they now run it as their
headquarters malik was going to rename
it
however after realizing that everyone
he'd brought there
inevitably had a tragic end he decided
to stick with the name
malik reveals that he's been able to see
into the future due to a device called
the time stream
which was sent back from the future by
the chronocoms
it's revealed that the time stream is
actually a sort of communication device
with sybil
that allows her to reveal the future to
whoever enters it
it's kind of funny that she's pretty
much become a fortune teller at this
point
but i'm sure that she's going to be back
and better than ever
we're also introduced to dr grady i
think this might actually be a nod to
eric o'grady
who's a villain from marvel comics grady
was a hydra goon that was masquerading
as a low-level shield agent
and he gained access to pin particles
which allowed him to develop a new
ant-man's suit for hydra
which he inevitably ended up stealing
malik does say that grady was killed
because his tech was too dangerous
i definitely think that it lines up with
the character in some ways
jon enters the time stream and though we
don't see it fully
he's probably just binging all of agents
of shield
available now on disney plus now at the
lighthouse the group tells jaya ying
that malik has been stealing and human
powers
and thus he and his group are becoming
more and more powerful
they go back and forth over what the
plan should be and even suggest
sending yo-yo in but realize that if
malik gets access to her abilities
he's going to be far too dangerous
colton states that he should be the one
to go in
due to being recyclable and thus they
make a plan to teleport in with gordon
and take over the base they also state
that jaya ying should remain
behind mainly to keep the timeline
intact and it's at this point that daisy
finds out she has a sister
she's completely blindsided by this and
angrily storms off
furious at may for not telling her may
warn her
that his sister isn't as nice as she is
and this was exemplified last week when
cora destroyed all of the wine glasses
on the table when training
daisy did the same exercise and made
music with them
so we know the two aren't really on the
same side morally
now i have seen a lot of people confused
about why we've never heard of korra
until this season
though there has been theories that
she's a new addition to the timeline
we learn that she was actually always
part of it
cora did succeed in killing herself
originally
however the introduction of nathaniel
into this version of reality
stayed a hand and thus she continued
living daisy starts to wonder
over whether her death caused her mother
to leave afterlife
and therefore meet her father thus if
cora didn't kill herself
she would never be born and yeah it's a
it's a lot of timey why me wibbly wobbly
stuff
and after life we see the powers machine
in full force
as lee's abilities are transferred into
a soldier named durant
this of course ties in with the title of
the episode stolen
but it goes far beyond that as you sort
of get the feeling that one of the big
characters
gets their life stolen by the events
that play out
malik states that his mission is to take
down shield because they don't have the
right to decide who lives and who dies
and though this is a questionable thing
that we can go back and forth over
i think deep down we will know that the
chronic comes are only manipulating the
events to destroy shield
which is what has been their endgame
this entire season cora kills lee after
malik instructs her to do so
and i love how we kind of have malik
controlling cora
whilst he's simultaneously being
controlled by the chronocoms
elsewhere on the zephyr we see deke with
headphones on dancing around the time
drive
and simmons comes to talk to him about
losing enoch
we've been told throughout the series
that the time drive is communicating
with fitz
however simmons shuts down this idea
saying that he may not actually be
controlling the time jumps
they all seem to be automated and that's
why since the chrono comes were pretty
much destroyed
the jumps have been at random simmons
hints that bits may actually be dead
and this is why the memories are too
painful to recall
let's be honest she would struggle with
completing the mission if grief was
looming over her head
and is possible that the chip is in
place on the back of her neck to keep
her moving along
i actually also think that it's in place
to protect the pair's daughter
which they likely had before the time
travel mission this would explain why
deke was eventually able to be born
and still have fits out of the picture
which is
how he seems to be though they think
that fits as the one doing the
calculations
there's also potential that it's
actually the pair's daughter
which simmons has had to abandon too
because of the mission
we obviously don't know for definite yet
and deke is still clearly in denial
but it's fun to theorize over these
things and hopefully
we still get to see fitz now simmons may
end up with an
alternate version of the character
similar to steve rogers and peggy
if all this timeline shenanigans
continues and yeah i just hope we get a
happy ending with the pair reuniting
the quinjet lands outside of afterlife
and gordon teleports himself
and coulson into the base upon arriving
there gordon is shot in the back
and malik takes coulson captive colson
tries to explain what's really going on
with the chronicoms
but it falls on deaf ears due to malek
being angry over shield killing his
father
malik explains that he wants to
introduce some anarchy and this is a
call back to the thing that he said to
korra upon taking over afterlife in
episode viii
they take colson to garrett who boasts
about all the times he watched him die
and garrix states his favorite one was
the long-haired creeper
stabbing him with the pointy stick which
is a reference to colton's death in the
avengers at the hands of loki
this pretty much started the agents of
shield series
and as coulson says they're playing all
their greatest hits
at the lighthouse souza catches up with
daisy and the two talk about her mother
daisy really wants to talk to jaya ying
but worries about the timeline
however souza says that due to
everything being screwed it won't really
make much of a difference
they go to her and talk about how
important afterlife is
jaya ying says there's never been an
outsider there before
but suzy rebuffs this and daisy gets to
show her powers
she makes music from a glass and this is
of course a call back to the
aforementioned wine trick
jai ying puts two and two together and
realizes that malek stole her powers
and she begins to talk openly about her
daughter cora which
daisy relates to due to also being her
daughter
she doesn't drop this bombshell on jaya
ying but clearly the two are on the same
page
after daisy's reveal of the future jaya
ying talks about what she would do as a
mother
and though she doesn't quite know yet it
does show that she
does express some regret over what
eventually happened to them in the
original timeline
it's this kind of closure i'd been
hoping to see these two get since they
parted ways
and i'm glad that they at least get to
have this very very short-lived moment
mark decides to go into afterlife
and at the base we see his gordon's
powers are going to be transferred into
gary
he begins to freak out over potentially
losing his eyes
and teleports then becoming ecstatic
over being able to jump about
i loved how he thanked coulson for
coming up with the word teleport
and man seeing a paxton back in any form
is brilliant to watch garrett teleports
with malik to the lighthouse
and they even find a deep squad t-shirt
and lock up
which is of course a nod to de-expand in
episode 7.
the two split up and at afterlife gordon
helps coulson teleport out of the cell
which is actually the same one that we
saw korra being held in a couple of
entries ago
gordon dies and this is quite a big
moment as
he was a big part of the main timeline
so it further knocks everything out of
sync
may discovers garrett in the lighthouse
and he recognizes her from the time
stream
which causes him to taunt her over the
events she just kicks the crap out of
him though
which makes him retreat to another part
of the base they're seemingly coming
after jaya ying for her immortality
and malek catches up with them in a
corridor he reveals that daisy is
jayang's daughter
and tells her about why they ended up on
opposite sides
but before he can reveal how she died
daisy busts him up with the quake powers
and the two go head to head
jaya ying begins to join his abilities
and then
malek kills her this sends daisy into a
rage-filled breakdown
and mae shows up and shoots malik
forcing him to flee
daisy cowers over her mother's body and
the fact that she's dead and daisy
doesn't disappear
could also cement how deak is still in
the timeline even though fitz
may no longer be in the land of the
living however jaya ying
can come back to life so yeah there is
still room here to really go either way
now it's at this point that it's
revealed that malik is actually there
for simmons
and garrett teleports in and takes her
out before susa can do anything
at the base yo-yo and colson meet up
inside afterlife
and the former two take out the guard
durant who's now using these powers
coulson then comes across cora and holds
her at gunpoint
coulson says that her team's abandoned
her and as soon as she brings up daisy
calls and shoots her which does cement
just how protective he is over her
he takes her to the quinjet and on the
zephyr we watch as garrett and malik
arrive
due to deek having headphones on he
doesn't hear the radio
and the four fly off into parts unknown
yikes
now in the end stinger we see gara
excited at just how good the day is
going
and malik explains to simmons that
they've played out every scenario
and the ones in which they lose are
because of fits they want simmons to
take them to him
however as we've said he may or may not
be dead
now i am as you can probably guess going
back and forth on this
because there's a lot of things still up
in the air from here on out in the video
though
we will be talking about the promo for
next week so if you don't want to know
anything
then i recommend that you turn off now
you're still here thanks for sticking
around
and in the trailer for next time we
don't actually see fits at all
so yeah it's gonna be another one of
those as i said earlier
i'm not sure if the character is still
around and do you think that their
daughter diana may be the one
controlling all the time jumps
however if fitz is alive then he'll no
doubt be even more angered that malik
and co have kidnapped simmons
so will likely be coming after them in
full force in order to rescue his wife
this could end up leading to his arrival
but as i've said
i still have no idea you also see that
daisy and cora are finally coming face
to face
and that the latter wants to make the
world a better place by
well murdering people yay now obviously
daisy
is going to put a stop to this very fast
but it's not like
she didn't want to make the timeline
better by murdering the malex early on
so who knows maybe they'll find some
common ground now the trailer also shows
the zephyr off in space
arriving at a portal that looks like the
chrono comes
but this could be fit intercepting them
but i am leaning more towards the former
look
i don't know and with the way things are
playing out anything could really happen
at this point
with just one episode until the finale
it's all heating up
and i am on board and really can't wait
to see what happens
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the 10th entry so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and if you missed our
analysis of any of the other episodes
then make sure you check them out after
this
don't forget that every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays and all
you have to do to be with the chance of
winning the mcu infinity saga box set
is leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on if you want to support
the channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat to
us on our discord server linked in the
description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you